Vừa qua, công ty hả nội mê trô phối hợp với các đơn vị chức năng kiểm tra dự chữa
nhiều hạn mục xuống cấp tại tuyến mê trô cấp lình hà đông.
Tuyến mê trô cắt lình hà đông đi vào hợp từ tháng 12, mùa tâm hành hình khung trong 20 mốt.
H hiện đặc bất lộ nhiều giấu hiệu xuống cấp sơ bún năm khai thác.
Đên vị đã thay mới toàn bộ mại trây thăng cuốn và lối đi bộ hương hồng.
Tại các nhà gà thái hả, vận đe ba, văn quan và in nghĩa,
vinh gái in nghĩa dự kiến hòn tất sử dựa mại trứa phóng em ngủ năm tháng 6.
Công tắc bởi vì mại trẻ cũng đang được dự chí thường xuyên.
Về thêm bị, hà bởi mấy trô đại sửa năm 18,
thay năm 18, mì hà gà và đưa trình tạm thời hệ thống hình thị dựa tàu.
Gựa sửa chữ ở mại bản đệ tự động dễ hoàn tất vào tháng 10 năm 18,
gió phay đặt phụ tụm dây.
Hệ thống tháng 18, tháng 9, đặc tăng cường biểm tra,
hà thêm bị gặp lối kiện thuật tại gà thượng đình và phụng khoảng.
Đăng được khắc phục dự kiến hòn tháng 7, mùa sấu.
Ngoài ra, mấy nước quân công cầm tại gà lá khi sẽ được bảo quản và nghen cứu tại dựa dụng,
nếu hệ khách định đã phụ hợp.